what we're going to do in this video is
think about two wave sources but one of
them is going to be stationary and the
other one is going to be moving and just
to have a concrete number it's moving at
five meters per second to the right and
we're going to think about is where are
the crests of the wave that it's been
releasing for the last three or four
seconds so let's say they're in both
cases they are releasing a wave so the
velocity of the wave is going to be 10
meters per second you could visualize
this maybe as a sound wave but sound and
air moves much much much much faster
than 10 meters per second but this will
make the math work out easy especially
relative to this guy who's moving to the
right at 5 meters per second and that's
the whole point to give you the
intuition and make the math a little
simple here and both of these guys are
going to be the wave that they're
emitting is it 10 meters per second and
the period of the wave is going to be at
1 second per cycle and if the period is
1 second per cycle you take the inverse
of that the frequency of the of the
source I guess you could call it of the
wave as it's being emitted is going to
be the inverse of this the inverse of 1
is just 1 but one cycle one cycle per
second if it takes a second for a cycle
it's also in one second you're also
going to see one cycle so one cycle per
second so let's think about what's
happening here so let's think about
where let's say it emitted a crest of
its wave exactly one second ago where is
that crest going to be now let's think
about the stationery character well in
this guy emitted the crest one second
ago it's moving outward so this is
outward it's moving outward rade
radially I need to give a direction if
I'm giving a vector quantity so it's
moving outward at 10 meters per second
so if it emitted it one second ago it's
going to be 10 meters radially outward
from the source so maybe that is right
over right over there it looks let me
draw it a little bit neater like that
let me draw it a little bit neater
that's pretty good so that's where that
crest will be now what about this guy
where is the crest that this guy emitted
one second ago well you might want to
just draw a radius 10 meter
around this guy as well but he wasn't
here one second ago he was 5 meters to
the left remember he's moving 5 meters
per second to the right so 1 second ago
he was 5 meters to the left so maybe
that places him right over there so the
the crest that he emitted 1 second ago
isn't going to be or it's not going to
be 10 meters from this guy it's going to
be 10 meters radially outward from that
guy so let me just copy and paste this
right here so copy and paste and just
put it right over there so this is where
he is now that's where he was 1 second
ago where he emitted this crest that has
now traveled 10 meters away this is a
little inexact so I could a little bit
like that this is 5 meters that's 10
meters away but you get the general idea
now let's keep going let's think about
the crest that both of these guys
emitted two seconds ago so this guy's
been stationary the whole time if he
emitted it two seconds ago it's
traveling at 10 meters per second it's
going to be 20 meters radially outward
from the center from the source so it
will be it will look something something
like that I'm just drawing the crests of
the waves if you think of a water pebble
being dropped into pond these are just
the high points on the on the wave that
spreads radially outward from where the
pebble was dropped now this guy once
again you can't just draw a circle
around this because he wasn't here two
seconds ago he was right here he was
right here two seconds ago one second
ago he was five meters to the left a
second before that he was five meters
more to the left so that wave that he
made it then is going to be 20 meters
radial outward from this point and so
let me just copy and paste this right
here so copy and paste so the center
isn't going to be that or that it's
going to be that point where he was two
seconds ago let's do this again let's do
it again let me use pink so what about
the crest that either of these sources
emitted three seconds ago well do it
would be
thirty meters radially outward so
another ten meters from the last one so
it will be it will be out here it will
be out there just like that this guy's
been stationary the whole time but what
about this guy well he wasn't here ten
meter once a three seconds ago he was
here right one second ago here two
seconds ago there three seconds ago
there so we're going to be thirty meters
radially outward from this point so once
again I can just copy and paste this
right here so copy and paste and it
should be centered around that point
around that point right there now let's
think a little bit about what what the
perceived frequency of this wave would
be for a couple of observers so we could
put an observer here really anywhere
around this guy we could put an observer
right here and then we could put another
observer right here now what's this guy
going to perceive well every second he's
getting a pulse being well there's a
couple of things to think about first of
all what is the wavelength of at least
this wave right here well every second
he's emitting a pulse so a second ago
the pulse is out there would have
traveled ten meters and then he emits
another pulse so the pulses are going to
be one second apart but since they
travel ten meters in that one second
they're also going to be ten meters
apart so the wavelength in this case is
going to be ten meters the distance
between these crests are ten meters now
what about this situation right here
what depends on kind of what side
whether the source is coming towards you
or whether it's going away from you
that's the situation with this guy in
this when it's when it's moving towards
you it's emitting a pulse so let's say
it emitted a pulse right here and then
it moves five meters to the right before
emitting the next pulse so instead of
them being ten meters apart in this case
this guy has kind of closed the distance
by five meters over here so these pulses
are only going to be five meters apart
so over here the wavelength is only five
meters and you can see it visually this
distance right here is half of this disk
these are five meters apart and on the
left-hand side if you're on the the side
of the source that is open that the
source is moving away from it would be
ten meters but every second the source
is also moving five more meters away
from you so this wavelength right here
this perceived wavelength right here is
going to be fifteen meters it's 15
meters and we can see it visually that's
the whole reason why I drew it this way
now what's going to be the perceived
frequencies for this well this guy you
know he has one crest passing him right
now it's going to take exactly one
second for the next crest to get to him
because there's traveling at 10 meters
per second so he is going to perceive he
is going to perceive one crest or one
cycle per second or one a frequency of
one Hertz which makes sense this is
stationary they're both stationary
relative to each other and we're also
talking about classical physics we're
not getting into relativity and all of
that but the observed frequency is the
exact frequency that was emitted by this
guy right there now what about this
situation well each of these crests are
five meters apart for this guy you know
if you imagine that this was some type
of a train coming to towards this guy
each of these crests are only five
meters apart but they're traveling at 10
meters per second so how many crests are
you going to see in a second we're going
to see two of them this one's going to
take half a second to reach you and then
the next half a second this one's going
to get to you or you could say this
one's takes half a second to reach you
then this one's going to take one second
to reach you so you're going to see two
so there's two ways to think of it you
could say your period in this situation
is one half of a second per cycle or you
could invert it and you could say that
the frequency observed we can put the
observed frequency is going to be two
cycles per second and already notice
this guy's experiencing a higher
frequency than this guy over here
because these wave fronts or these
crests are just passing by him more
frequently because they were because
this guy is moving in the same direction
as this guy they are closer together now
this guy's going to experience the
opposite thing let's say that this crest
is just passing him by how long will it
take for the next crest to cover that
meters well they're going at 10 meters
per second it's going to be 1.5 seconds
seconds per crest that's going to be the
observed period for this guy you take
the inverse of that that's 1.5 is
three-halves it's two-thirds of a or you
can say crest or 2/3 of a cycle per
second so when the source is moving away
from this observer the frequency or the
perceived frequency is lower than the
frequency of of the actual emitted wave
when the source is moving towards the
observer the frequency is higher this
might seem something some type of
bizarre thing but you've experienced
before it's called the Doppler effect
which you've probably heard of and
that's exactly what you experience when
you sit at you know at maybe a train
crossing be careful not to sit too close
and as a train is approaching you you
notice it has a very say it has its horn
going on it be very high-pitched and
then right when it passes you and it
starts moving away from you it starts it
has a much lower pitch and that
perceived pitch that's your that's your
brain in your ears way of sensing
frequency so when the train is coming
towards you it's a high pitch high
frequency when it's going away from you
low pitch low frequency and hopefully
drawing it out this way gives you a
visual understanding of why that is why
these these points on the cycle or these
crests are closer together when it's
moving in your direction and when
they're farther apart when it's moving
away from you and the next video we'll
do this with more abstract numbers so we
can actually figure out generalized
formulas for relating the observed
frequency with the emitted frequency